ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'éducation nationale et de
la jeunesse la question de notre
jeunesse est plurielle tant elle
représente notre diversité et notre
héritage elle est aussi la clé de voûte
de la société de demain mais aujourd'hui
quel avenir lui offrons-nous je sais que
cette question vous anime tout autant
que moi c'est pourquoi plus que d'y
réfléchir philosophiquement nous devons
d'y répondre concrètement
sans tomber dans les excès et les
raccourcis notre jeunesse nous expose
quotidiennement ses attentes ses peurs
et sa colère sa colère contre une
société qui détruit sa nature contre une
société où l'homophobie et les
discriminations existent encore une
société où les violents ou les jeunes
victimes auteurs font face à de la
violence dans leur quotidien
l'actualité nous le rappelle encore
aujourd'hui et nous montre l'impact
qu'elle peut avoir sur leur comportement
et leur confiance il y a cinq ans déjà
je m'exprimais à ce même micro face à un
ministre différent certes mais sur le
même sujet si depuis 5 ans nous avons
nous pouvons noter plusieurs avancées
sur le harcèlement le code pénal des
mineurs le droit des enfants il est
toujours heureux pour moi de constater
qu'il y a encore tant à faire alors
Monsieur le Ministre donnant un coup de
pouce à cette jeunesse donnant lui
confiance en l'avenir car il y a une
qualité de que cette jeunesse garde
toujours c'est sa capacité à refuser un
futur incertain son optimisme et sa
persévérance redonne espoir
mobilisons-nous nous devons nous nous
devons de la protéger et de lui
permettre de s'épanouir et de
s'émanciper ces notes devoir d'adultes
mais c'est surtout notre responsabilité
d'hommes et de femmes politiques et
l'État doit être en être le garant
notre jeunesse peut-être avoir confiance
en l'état
nos institutions sont-elles toujours en
phase avec ces attentes
quelle grande politique de protection de
prévention et d'accompagnement devant
nous mettre en place monsieur le
ministre Créon pour notre avenir une
grande politique de la jeunesse